- Why do I think a lot
of you don't do shit?
Because you value other
people's opinions of you.
(upbeat hip hop music)
- [Both] Hey!
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
(cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat hip-hop music)
As you guys know, it's 2017.
So much of my thesis's and
ideas are available on YouTube,
but the fact that we're here together,
I think what I've learned
in this environment,
is if you go selfish, and
ask a very specific question,
that you think that I might be
able to bring some value to,
a lot of times, 80% of the
room has also got something
similar that's going through their minds,
so if I can encourage
the table that's got the
green thing right now,
if you want to ask the first question,
and then on the left side here,
if you guys wanna line up behind this mic
to ask your questions.
I think, you know, if
you wanna go high level.
You know to me, the world is broken up
into branding and sales.
So people in here are thinking about
converting and selling something.
In what I would call, below
the funnel, kind of like,
just transactional sales.
And then I think, for a lot
of you that watch what I do,
I spend a lot more time
selling at the brand level.
There's no real ask.
There's no right hook.
It's about, to be very frank
with you, guilting people
into opportunities and building brand.
Like nobody here, especially
in groups like this,
you know, especially knowing
a lot about what I know about
at this point,
like I think a lot of the conversation
should be how brand lowers
cost of acquisition.
But then, a lot of you
are business owners.
Like I've built two businesses,
a lot of culture, HR,
human retention, hunting,
farming, so you know,
anything as basic as like,
how do I make Snapchat sell me shit.
Like I'm thrilled to answer anything.
You can go anywhere.
You know, you wanna talk about
the bullshit call yesterday
in the Jets game.
I'm thrilled to answer anything.
(audience laughing)
- That was bullshit.
- The tight end.
- I don't even wanna, please
don't even get me started.
I'd love to help, so.
- [Carlos] Hi, Gary.
- What's your name, my man?
- [Carlos] Carlos.
- Carlos.
- Okay, I really appreciate the time.
I love you, I love your work.
(Gary laughing)
Gary Vee, you know, Jab Jab Right Hook.
- [Gary] Thank you, sir.
- [Carlos] And I have formal delays.
- [Gary] No problem.
(muffled man's voice speaking)
- [Gary] Yes.
- You know, I'm a social media coach.
- I have a name, I have a
certain degree of a brand.
- [Gary] Understood.
- People who are aware.
- But I haven't invested in the steps
that sometimes you point out,
so if you were to give me advice.
I have a reputation--
- [Gary] Yes.
- I have a following.
- But I haven't tapped
into what it is that,
is it Facebook?
Is it Youtube?
- [Gary] Well--
- Is it a combination of the two?
- [Gary] What's your gut?
Before I answer it and I'm thrilled to.
What's your intuition on what you
haven't really done enough of?
(muffled speaking)
- [Gary] I'm sorry?
- [Gary] Yeah.
(muffled speaking)
- [Gary] Yes.
- Then I walk out there,
I didn't capture footage.
I mean, I guess elements
have to be placed, structure.
You know, I can spend the time with it.
But I mean, I can do a video.
Several guys here have talked to me.
They watch the commenting output.
- [Gary] Yes.
(muffled speaking)
- [Gary] Understood.
- But I came for you,
you are one of the God's
of social media and being here
because you cut the bullshit.
You tell us it is.
(muffled speaking)
So I don't know, I mean, I'm just saying,
if I have the gift of
being an instructor--
- [Gary] Yes.
- That came close to before
and after and experience
every single personal goal--
- [Gary] Yes.
- And I don't tell this just to brag--
- [Gary] Don't worry,
you'll never brag as much
as me so we'll be fine.
(crowd laughing)
- [Gary] Yeah.
(muffled voice)
- And then one like going back home
with my beautiful wife, you know,
they say you have nothing to do with it.
You know, there's no monetizing.
- [Gary] No, I totally get it.
(muffled speaking)
- I'm not trying to say that
to bring attention to me.
(muffled speaking)
- [Gary] Carlos, right?
What's his first name?
- [Man's Voice] Carlos
(quietly speaking last name)
- [Gary] So Carlos, yeah.
I'll give it to you.
Carlos, I think what's very obvious,
look for all of us, there's
the message and distribution.
Right?
You know whatever you're version
of what Carlos is feeling
about his skillset, we all have it.
I think the biggest thing
that I could tell you,
you know a lot of times when I speak
I'm always thinking about what can I say
that changes the outcome
of the room, right?
The reason I love doing
Q and A is I think that
most speakers are too self serving,
and I think when you
speak you need to have
empathy and you need to deliver, right?
So when I hear that question
what I'm excited about is
right off the bat we're five seconds in
and you asked a question Carlos,
that I think is probably
the most important thing
I could leave here with,
which is if I could get
even one person to execute
on what I'm about to say
that person's impact on their
to your point,
I think much more about my
legacy than my currency.
When you've got something to say,
you know you pretty quickly get away
from worrying about the money.
You get into,
"Shit I wanna get this
all out before I'm gone."
Right?
So for me, the biggest thing
that I wanna say is that
the second everybody in this room
realizes that they're
a media company first
and then whatever they
do for a living, second,
everything will change.
When I hear what you say, I say
well that guy needs a
full time Editor in Chief,
around brand Carlos.
You should film everything.
You should turn all
that filming into audio.
All that audio should be
turned into written word.
I think of myself at this
point as a triple threat
as a media company.
I'm putting out tons of video,
tons of audio, and tons of written word.
How many people here listen
to my podcast, right?
I mean that's crazy,
that's most of this room,
and like two years ago
I wasn't even thinking about audio, right?
But as we've gotten busier, audio's grown,
cause it's passive, you can listen to me
while you're doing other shit.
If you wanna watch my video,
you gotta watch the video, right?
So everything keeps changing.
Carlos, I think the first thing
that you need to think about
is you sorta need to
thinking about yourself
as ESPN and HBO and CNBC
and the New York Times.
The quicker all of you
think of yourself as that
everything changes.
I literally think that I Gary Vee,
don't compete with Richard Branson
or with you know Mark Cuban,
I think that Gary Vee
competes with Business Insider
and Forbes, and you know
the Wall Street Journal, Complex Magazine.
Like I don't think about
competing with humans.
I spend zero time even debating that.
And so I think of myself
Carlos as a media company.
You know what I think a lot
of people do in our world?
They turn into infomercials versus 20 20.
If you make content on Facebook,
and LinkedIn, and your
email, and everything you do.
If you think of yourself as ABC news.
If you think about yourself as Fox or CNN,
instead of an infomercial, shit changes.
And so I highly recommend that all of you,
and especially you if you're
sitting on something like that,
everybody's thinking like an advertiser,
not as a media company.
And I think for a lot of you
it seems like you know I'm
watching your kind of behavior,
that's why I feel a little bit different.
I'm not putting out content
like an advertiser with a short term goal.
I'm putting out content
like a media company
with a long term goal.
Which creates short term opportunity.
It's a very very subtle but
disproportionate reason,
and the luckier you are,
if you're this legendary
as people whispering to me,
well that means you're
sitting with something
which means you should
be recording all of it,
all of it.
(Carlos muffled speaking)
- That's right,
and the way to think about it is
some of you don't' have the
dollars to hire somebody yet,
and neither did I the first eight years.
The whole DRock now and all this.
I love when everyone's like,
easy for you Gary, you have Drock now.
I'm like dick, I didn't
have anybody for eight years
and I built up to it,
and then I had somebody.
So like if you gotta do
it in selfie form, good.
Like for me, I can't write,
I have a ghost writer for my books,
I have a ghost writer for my
LinkedIn and Medium right now.
I can't write, it's not how I communicate,
but I can do video.
Some of you are scared of
video, and get awkward,
you're more introverted, so then write.
Use the medium that helps
you best communicate,
and then build around it.
So maybe you write,
and maybe somebody makes video content
transcribing your
written words into audio.
Like you just gotta bat
against what your good at,
but you've got to fill
out all the other ways
'cause people are consuming
content in different forms.
I don't want discriminate
on how you guys want to consume me.
You wanna listen while
you're brushing your teeth?
Mazel tov.
You wanna read on the way to your office?
Great.
You wanna watch a video
'cause you need a boost,
and you need to see the insanity?
Great.
I just don't want to be the judge,
and too many people are making content
that they would consume.
I only think about you, not me.
You need to put out everything.
The quicker you take money,
and this is for a lot of you in the room
'cause there's a lot of
business people here,
the quicker you take your money
and put it into another
person that helps you
make more content,
versus buying some shit for yourself,
the quicker you build an
actual fucking business.
Cool.
(audience applauds)
I think it's gonna be
on in a minute I hope.
Let's see, try again.
Not yet?
How 'bout now?
Nope, how 'bout now?
(audience laughing)
You can but I wanna make
sure they get the audio.
Okay.
We'll try to fix that while
we give you the Catchbox.
- [Daniel] Hello?
- [Gary] There we go.
Right in the nick of time.
What's your name man?
- [Daniel] Daniel.
- [Gary] Pleasure.
- [Daniel] Pleasure to meet you.
- [Gary] Thanks brother.
- [Daniel] Absolutely,
watch all your stuff.
So I wanna hear more about
Gary Veeaynerchuk CEO.
You were talking a lot just now
about investing your money
back into getting more people.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And so I'm fascinated
about what you believe
as far as like having applied silver
and the heart altzer and
everything along with those lines.
And I'd really appreciate it if
you could go very tactical
with the people in this room.
You know we have much smaller
companies, most of us.
As we're building them up,
what are some do's and don'ts
as we're trying to find
some winning players.
- So play with me here so
you can help everybody.
The number one thing I always do
is first try to figure out
what I'm trying to accomplish.
So for me, Carlos back
to you, recalling you,
I wanted to set out, to not
only buy the New York Jets
but to have a legacy in
the entrepreneur space
that was the perfect balance
between making a lot of
money and being successful
and doing it in the best human way.
I wanted to be the nicest,
most successful person.
I don't need to make the most money
I just needed to do it in the best way.
Help other people along the way.
Help my people along the way.
It does a lot of weird things.
So for example, you have to know yourself.
If you're in it for the money,
there's nothing wrong with that.
You just need to know that.
So for example because
I knew I wanted legacy
even as a 23 year old,
when I started running my dad's business
the first year I ran the business
it went from three to ten million.
That's like fuck, like that
changes everything right?
Even the way I fired people,
like the severances I
give are so ridiculous
like this is just a truth,
I hate to call my dad out
he would have somebody work
for him for seven years
fire them and not give them anything.
Very Russian.
I had people work for me for a month
and I've given them
three months severance.
You know like, it's not because I'm
a better person than my dad.
It's because I knew
what I've set out to do.
So the first thing I tell all of you
is figure out what
you're setting out to do.
Both from a financial standpoint,
and a reputation and legacy standpoint.
'Cause once you understand
what you're trying to achieve,
How much you wanna make.
What do you wanna do with your money.
What's your work life balance.
Where do you sit on the pantheon?
Is it just about the dollars?
Is it not?
Are you leaving it to your kids?
Are you selling it to go fish?
What are you doing?
Because this is the biggest reason,
my man Daniel that a lot of people
aren't doing the things
that they need to do?
'Cause they're just kind of,
It's just about the money.
They're in a rat race of
this year I wanna make
100,000 next year 400,
you wanna pay your debt off from school,
or buy your mom a house.
It's very very narrow,
and I started right from 15 thinking about
who I was gonna be at 90
and working backwards.
So that's number one,
but the reason I started macro
to go very tactical on you
is because I know I don't
wanna sell VaynerMedia.
I don't have to maximize
the ibadah of the business.
I don't need to maximize the profit
of VaynerMedia year in and year out,
because I'm not selling it.
So I never have the worry,
that someone's gonna swoop in
and offer me money for my business
and then when I look at the bottom line
I wanna make sure the profits
real good for that sale.
I never have to spend a year or two,
setting it up for the sale.
I, just to get everybody grounded,
have decided to build the
best marketing machine.
I always call it the Comms
and Marketing Death Star,
except without the little
flaw that Luke fucking shot.
I don't want it to go
away. (crowd laughing)
So like I wanna build the
greatest marketing machine of all time.
And in my 50s, 60s, and 70s,
I wanna buy very big businesses
like Reebok or Yahoo chocolate drink
or Gymboree, like big businesses you know
and I wanna buy them and run
them through the machine.
Buy them for 408 million, sell
them for 3.7 billion right?
Like that's why I'm doing it.
So again, I'm giving a long winded answer
'cause we got some time together.
Now you know why I have
a chief heart officer
and why Claude's the
most important person.
I spend all my time on HR,
either thinking about it,
or spending time with my employees
'cause it's family.
If I was gonna sell it in
four years, I wouldn't!
I wouldn't spend all my
time with my employees.
You know a lot of times people are like
Gary you're the best.
Somebody like you really knows my shit,
I've hired a chief heart officer,
and I'm gonna spend all my time on HR.
And I'm like what are you doing?
They're like,
"Oh I'm gonna build this up
and sell it in two years."
And I'm like, you shouldn't
spend any time with anybody.
You need to maximize
profits, and lower costs.
You probably want people
quitting to lower costs,
like you want attrition so
what I've done my whole career
is I realize people are
the variable of success.
There's way too much ego in business.
Like humility and empathy
are your secret powers.
Everybody wants to be the man, be the guy,
be the gal, be the one, be the girl.
Like everybody wants to be that person.
And I just basically every
morning wake up and know
that I work for everybody
and nobody works for me
as the CEO.
You know how many people
here struggle with expecting
people that work for them
to work as hard as them?
(audience chuckles)
- All of you.
- I mean just ludicrous
ludicrous audacity at best
and straight fucking
asshole-ishness at worst, right?
So like, I think about this shit everyday
like you know, for me it's people-centric.
You know like people are always like,
I can't get my cashiers
to like fucking work
'cause they're only twelve bucks an hour
I'm like no it's 'cause you've never
said hello to them, dickface.
(audience laughing)
Right?
So like I'm very people-centric.
I think theirs enormous ROI,
either in the short term or the long term.
Some of the people that work for me,
Iris may go on to win
an academy award as a film maker right?
Like I'd much rather have
her like me than not like me.
You know and everybody's
playing short term.
I don't live as if tomorrow I'm gonna die,
and I'm stunned by how many people do.
It's all short term ROI.
Every decision is short term ROI.
And I think that's a huge decision.
So internally I spend a
lot of time and money.
My HR department, too big.
My time that I spend
with employees, too much.
This is what I hear from
all my business associates.
Who then spend all their
time asking me how I do it.
(audience laughing)
So, you know, I'm a big culture guy.
I agree with you,
like my intuition is that 94% of this room
is not culture oriented.
They're money oriented.
It's just the way it is.
It's not because of this room,
it's because of every room
of every business
conversation in the world
and in that arbitrage, I'm
gonna build a huge legacy
and buy the New York Jets.
And so I think that everybody here
should take a step back
and realize what actually
drives their business.
I'm looking around and there
are a lot of youngsters here,
including you, how old are you?
- [Daniel] 27.
- Yeah you've never been
punched in the mouth, right?
Meaning.
- [Daniel] Well I mean literally maybe.
(audience laughs)
- You know, I worry about people under 30
who've been basically
navigating their careers
during good economic
times basically since 2009
we've been growing.
Right so for a couple of
us a little older here,
we remember the morning of Bear Stearns
we remember the April 2000
economic bubble burst,
like until you get punched in the mouth,
you're not a real player.
So right now we have a
lot of people under 30
who need to realize when you
get punched in the mouth,
its those employees, and
humans that are the ones
that allow you to survive
it, not the other way around.
And so there's a lot of naivete,
there's a lot of inexperience,
and then there's a lot of short term
financial decision making.
So I interview all my senior people,
I spend an enormous amount of time,
telling them they'll get fired
if they don't play nice with
the other boys and girls.
The number one flaw that
a lot of people have
in their company right now
is their biggest money maker
is also their biggest asshole.
And they're letting them get away with it,
'cause of the money making that's creating
massive cancer internally
within organizations right now.
They should all be the best.
One of the biggest reasons
that I still be Gary Vee,
is 'cause I wanna be
the best at social media
so that I'm never at the
mercy of any of my employees.
I've never had an employee that's had any
significant leverage against me ever,
in the history of my career.
Which I've never even had a sales team
that's been bonused on sales.
I've just never put myself in the position
to be at the mercy of somebody.
And I think a lot of people do that.
So it's something to think about.
And then finally, you have
to know what they care about.
One of my best people
that runs Facebook ads
still works for me because I bought him
St. Louis Cardinals tickets,
because I knew he was a
St. Louis Cardinals fan.
And it meant so much to
him, that he's passed up
Facebook and Google offering him
50 to 100 thousand dollars
a year more in salary
because he feels good about me.
So some people trade on
money. which is great.
By the way, I wish everyone
one of my employees
traded on money,
it'd be simple.
How much do you want?
Good, I can do that,
Can't do that.
How much do you want?
I can do that.
Like that's easy.
The problem is a lot of your employees
work on work life balance.
A lot of your employees
completely trade on
you just acknowledging them.
I mean I can't wrap my head around
what's actually going on in the world.
Like how are you and owner
and not saying hello,
like who the fuck do you think you are?
So that's how I feel.
It's really how I feel.
I watch it, I watch managers and owners.
That's the reason so many people struggle
with going to management.
When they were Indians it was
fun to make fun of the chiefs.
But when you become a
chief, it's hard right?
It's a whole different game.
What got you to management
is nothing that gets
you to the next place.
You're the ultimate manager
if you own your shit.
You only work for everybody else.
The customer, your employees.
For me it's my employees first,
then the customer, then I
can even begin to think about
what the fucks in it for me.
And I've just watched 95% of
the businesses I interact with
start with them, then the
customer, then their employees.
I think that most of
the people are broken.
And I think that if you have,
if you're honest, no bullshit right?
If it just went through
your mind like fuck,
I am me, then customer, then my employees,
you will lose.
And I can tell you, that's
the majority of businesses.
Anything else I can add?
'Cause I know you wanted detail,
I went macro, I'd like to close some gap.
- [Daniel] Yeah, that
was awesome as always.
I was thinking like tactically,
what is the one thing
I should do or not do.
- How many employees do you have, if any?
- [Daniel] Nine.
- None?
- Nine.
You should talk to them and ask them
what they give a fuck about.
When's the last time, tell me the truth
don't lie in front of these people.
- [Daniel's Friend] Yeah, Dan.
(audience laughs)
- When's the last time
you've literally sat down
with all nine of them for 45 minutes
over breakfast, lunch, or dinner and said,
"What are the biggest things that
you're interested in for me to do?"
- [Daniel] Well he calls me at midnight
to asks me about other things,
so fairly often.
- And the other eight too?
- [Daniel] I'm sorry?
- And the other eight as well?
- [Daniel] No, sir.
- That's it my man.
I love it.
First of all, thank you for your honesty
and listen it seems like
your deep in my content
you've probably heard me recently say
I'm fucking up too.
I think this open door policy is working
it's not working for shit.
So next year I'm redoing
my whole schedule.
I'm not speaking at all next year.
I'm like doing like six
events compared to 40
just so I have more of the man hours
to now force every one of my 750 people
to have seen me for 15
minutes every six months.
So you have eight other employees
you should be done this week.
(audience laughing)
And here's how it goes Daniel:
Karen, Rick, Susan, the
fuck do you want from me?
What can I do for you?
You may find that she wants
to leave early on Fridays
cause she's missing recitals
and that changes her whole life.
That she'll dominate for you,
Monday through Friday and a
half just for those two hours.
Or maybe someone doesn't like
the way you're talking to them.
And so the number one
thing I do tactically
is not only do I sit down
with them for 15 minutes,
I'll spend the first 11 minutes
getting them comfortable
with telling me the truth.
And then I'll follow up with
a text with an emoji in it,
and then I'll watch what
they do on social media.
And then I'll pay attention
to who they're friends with.
I'm a full time listener.
Everybody thinks I talk all the time.
All I'm doing is listening.
The biggest reason I talk so much
is to get reactions from you
whether one on one, you
in an audience like this,
or the whole fucking
world when I do content.
I talk so much strategically to get
reaction so I can listen
so I can readjust.
You know its fun when I talk to
anything that even remotely
touches martial arts
because I didn't realize this
because I didn't know anything about it
like I'm all reactionary.
I'm all that, I'm a counter-puncher.
I'm doing things to force you into a move
so I can then do the next move.
It's chess.
I just do it with communication.
I even think that my
personality in hindsight
has developed into this
caricature of who I am
to create the natural reaction
because I'm able to
judge people very quickly
based on how they react to me.
- At what point do you
what do you hold on to?
You know, you're giving away great stuff
so I understand every time they hear you
they almost sound like oh I
get to make a little more.
But what do you hold on to?
- So here's what's interesting about me
that's a little different
I don't know if you
guys have paid attention
I have not set out to monetize my audience
like the majority of people
which I'm empathetic, I get it.
What makes me a little
tough to use as a proxy
is that I've always made my money
in a separate business
than my audience buying stuff from me.
Super easy to give
everything away for free
when you're not counting
on any of the money.
Right?
Here's the mistake everybody makes.
Everybody thinks you give
away some lightweight shit,
and you sell your best stuff.
That's what everybody does.
I think it's the other way around,
I give away all my best shit.
If I was selling my audience
I would give away all my best shit,
and then what I would sell is access.
Unscalable stuff.
Because if you're giving away bullshit
or just stuff that's just not that strong,
you're never gonna get them into the
interest graph to begin with.
The other thing is way
too many people think
they're sitting on something
that means something.
Information is commoditized.
People want to sell information,
I make fun of all my friends who think
they're going to make a 97 dollar ebook.
I'm like bro.
I'm like cool, but do you feel good about
selling somebody 97 dollars worth of shit
that you just control
copied from the internet?
So I think you hold onto
something that is not scalable.
So I think access is not scalable.
Your time is not scalable.
I think the best model
is to sell something
that is not scalable,
that's hard for you as
the individual to scale.
But then you can maximize it right?
I mean the amount of money people offer me
to spend an hour with me.
The emails I get are so crazy.
I had some guy send me 100
thousand dollars in my Paypal.
Just like sent it, and he's like one hour.
And I couldn't take it, I
just gave it to him for free.
But like what it told me was fuck
this is so right, this is so right.
So for all the people
that are trying to sell
and do all these things,
you know like doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
So what do you hold on to?
Something that isn't scalable.
What do you give away?
The best shit you got.
(muffled speaking)
- [Man In White Shirt] I
know you've done hundreds
of hours of podcasts or videos,
just tons and tons of video,
so it's very difficult for people to
go back and see all of it
so they'll hear bits and pieces--
- The notion of the curated content
as a packaged product is a fair debate
'cause time is valuable
and so for the people
who are really stuck,
who don't want to sell their time
or don't want to go with my model,
I think the one thing that
is a worthwhile debate
is if you curate all your stuff in one.
It's kind of how I think of a book right.
Like here's for 13 bucks
all the last year and a half
in one place.
So you know listen, I'm not god
here's my number one piece of advice,
if you feel great about what you sell,
sell whatever the fuck you want, right?
But make sure you're not feeling great
because of the selfish needs
for the financial impact on your life.
Make sure you feel great,
because you've looked at everything else
that they could spend their money on
and will it really work.
(audience applauds)
- Hey brother.
- [Man In Black Hoodie]
Can we actually get back to
when you did the first event?
- Yup I remember.
- [Man In Black Hoodie] I
recommend it to everybody.
- Thank you brother.
- [Man In Black Hoodie] First,
I wanna be historically correct by saying
that when you do the
book Perfectly Parented
I'm pumped about that,
cause it's going to catapult you.
I want Iris to kind of
bookmark my statement.
- You got it.
We got it, thank you.
For all of you that don't follow as hard
you know, just to give you context
I've been working on a book,
it's probably why it's not out
'cause it's my true passion project.
It's called Perfectly Parented:
How to Raise an Entrepreneur.
it's basically the story of
what my parents did for me.
You know it's really cool
with all the good things
that are happening with me in my life
I take zero credit.
I literally think if Vayner crushes it
I feel good, me.
But one of the reasons I can sit up here
and run the gamut of like
huge ego to huge humility
is my parents are the
reason I'm sitting here.
My parents and the fact that I was born in
a foreign country,
raised as an immigrant
here in the United States.
And really understand what's
actually happening here,
and how good it actually is.
And I lead with optimism not pessimism.
And so I appreciate that,
I can't wait to write it.
I need to make sure I write it.
- [Man In Black Hoodie] Absolutely.
I'll officially pre-order
the first 20 copies.
- [Gary] Done.
- A couple months ago on Daily Beast
you had a piece of advice, which I took.
You said that everyone should podcast,
but the problem is it's
going to be really hard
getting a Gary Vee, Tony
Robbins to sit down for an hour
but if someone did a
60 to 90 second podcast
you might have the serendipity
to be in the right place at the right time
to possibly get an amazing
person like Gary Vee
to do 60 seconds.
So my question is can I get
60 seconds on the way out?
- [Gary] Done, yes.
(audience applauds)
Let me make this valuable for everybody
not just his selfish needs and wants
which was super fun and I'm thrilled,
I can't wait to do it.
The advice going further will
really help a lot of you.
Please understand that time, is literally
besides health the number one asset.
So many of you ask for people to do things
that takes up their time
for your self interest,
you need to go the other way.
So much of what has made me successful
is creating less friction for you guys.
I got to the podcast 'cause I'm like
oh shit audio's happening
it's better for you guys
while you're running,
while you're traveling.
Let me put more money into
making a good podcast,
so I can create less friction for you.
A lot of people have these landing pages
and all this so you can get the data
so you can do your thing
you're creating friction.
Anything that makes it
better for the other person
when it comes to time.
Please keep that in mind.
That's why the advice I
gave to all these kids
and people that are starting podcasts.
They want superstars on their show,
sure who doesn't.
But the people that you want have no time.
So I was like fuck it,
start a show that's
like only a minute long.
That you can get somebody who's super busy
who just wants to get
out there a little bit.
We all do no matter where we are right?
Might be like oh that
sounds good, two minutes?
Cool.
So what do you dame it?
- [Man In Black Hoodie] It's
called The Mindset Minute.
- [Gary] The Mindset Minute.
How many have you done?
- You'll be 32.
- [Gary] How's it going?
- Really well.
- [Gary] Good man.
- I listen to it.
(audience laughs)
- [Gary] You've got one listener!
One's better than zero, bro.
The first two years I did
Wine Library t.v. on YouTube,
and people didn't even know
what YouTube was in 2006.
You know no body was watching.
18 months, nobody.
And I'm losing money at Wine Library
because I'm spending all this
time trying to build this.
But I knew, right?
You know how many celebrities
got fucked by Instagram
because three years
ago they didn't want to
jump into Instagram because
other people had a lot of followers
and they were a real celebrity.
And if they jumped on it
only had 10,000 followers
it would've made them look bad.
So what they did was they never started,
now they're not even a pseudo-celebrity
cause they never started.
Too much ego.
I'm thrilled to do everything because
what you gonna make fun of me
that my podcast is ranked
10,000 and I should be higher?
Fuck you.
You know what I mean?
Too many of you are not doing things
because you're worried about
how it's gonna make you look,
'cause you're late.
So you're not starting,
which is always a bad idea.
Right?
It's a huge thing that's happening.
You know I'm always thinking about
the soundbite that may help you.
I'm pumped right now because
I have funny a feeling
two or three of you are like fuck
maybe I should.
You know I get it,
I understand brand.
I understand shit, I'm supposed to be this
and I have less than all these.
But if you don't start, you don't get.
And by the way, cream
always rises to the top.
If you're so good, you'll be there.
So many people doing dumb shit.
You know how many people have
800,000 followers on Instagram
but they bought their
followers, or their accounts.
Smart people know.
So cool you tricked the 80% of idiots,
but the 20% of people that know
or the 1% that actually matter to know
think you're a loser and
a short carder, right?
Be smart.
So number one self awareness.
Again, one of the things I
think has really worked for me
that I think I'm putting
pressure in this room on,
don't bullshit yourself.
That's the quickest way to lose,
and we do it so much
because we come up with stuff
that we wish would happen
versus what we know will happen.
As far as an exit strategy
to me an evergreen
business is always great
unless you think you
have a moment in time.
Right so if you have 47
acai bowl food trucks
you may want to anticipate
that that food trend could change.
But if you have a real estate empire,
you know it goes up and down,
but it doesn't go away.
So you need to first
decide if your business
can go away outright, right?
And then finally,
just what are you going
to do with the money?
A lot of people sell their company,
with no real intent for the money.
Meaning they just like the idea of it
and they wanna buy some shit.
Which is fine, but like with
money being so cheap right now
and so little to put down on a mortgage.
Like what?
What do you need so bad,
you need to ask yourself.
So there's a matrix of moment in time,
evergreen versus selling it.
If you sell it,
look I mean I should've
probably sold a lot of things.
I was so right about
Facebook and Amazon stock
in the last seven years,
opportunity costs,
I should've liquidated everything.
If you know what you want
to do with the money,
and you understand what
you're getting yourself into.
But I've seen so many friends
build businesses for four, five years,
build something nice.
Sell it, because they see
some other opportunity.
They sell it.
That other opportunity was
nothing they knew anything about.
They take the money,
they put it into that,
that goes down.
They could've been five years later.
People don't like to work,
for some reason sometimes, right?
So like I never want to sell anything,
and never have really sold anything.
Because I like working, and building,
and evergreening and legacy.
But I'm also super empathetic.
My friends have sold a lot of companies
that they were right.
Buddy Media was right.
Mike Lazerow made 800 million dollars,
and it wouldn't have
been worth eight million
if he'd waited four years later.
So you have to be smart,
if it's a moment in time
there's a lot of different
variables, right?
Bebo sold to AOL for 850 million dollars,
'cause that was the social media
platform scares of the 2000s
with MySpace, and Facebook
and Bebo, and High5.
So you gotta figure out
how real your business is,
and what you're going to do with the money
but it's a very personal thing, right.
We're all going through our own shit,
like so much you know?
And then finally if you
know you're going to sell it
a lot of us entrepreneurs
are not fiscally great.
Like I'm great at revenue,
but I don't love the CFO
work of maximizing profit.
If you're deciding that like
in the next two or three
years you're gonna go,
I highly recommend bringing
in a strong financial partner,
whether a CFO or a controller right?
'Cause you know a lot of us,
and I'm making assumptions 'cause it feels
very entrepreneurial in here.
We're good at the selling part,
but the maximizing the profit
or what expansion looks like.
A lot of us entrepreneurs get caught
when we start getting to that next level.
And if you know you're going to sell,
they're gonna look very
hard at those financials
so you wanna start prepping yourself.
- [Guest] I appreciate it.
- You got it.
(audience applauds)
- [Mike] What's up Gary, I'm Mike.
- [Gary] Mike.
- I'm super excited to be
up here speaking with you.
- [Gary] Thanks brother.
- Plus there's so much of
your material out there,
and I don't think
there's anybody out there
who actually comes out more content
on as many platforms as you do.
So my question is on creativity.
If you ever sort of get
into a writers block
or creativity block, to
pump out so much material,
and what advice you have for
us who are creating podcasts
or creating Snapchat accounts.
How do you keep pumping
out that solid material.
- So this is something funny
that Iris and my team on the creative side
probably talk about behind my back
which is there's just
unlimited stream of content
that I'm just able to come up with.
To be very frank guys I mean this,
I just think I have a lot to say.
And not because I love
hearing myself talk,
which I do.
It's just that
I'm really gonna end up being known as
somebody who was really good.
I think I'm grossly underrated
for all the fandom I already have.
I really can feel it as I'm
starting to audit myself
against the A players of society.
I think I got lucky,
that my mom and dad had
sex at the right moment.
You know?
(audience laughs)
I mean it, it's DNA right?
The same that so many of you
whether you can sing, or play basketball
or rap, or draw, or be good at business.
There was a reason I was an anomaly
and an enigma when
entrepreneurship wasn't cool.
Like I've always had this thing
and so for me it comes very natural.
First of all I have eight
to 12 core principals,
and I'm very good at synthesizing culture,
and making it feel fresh even
though its the same shit.
And the only reason people here
have been following me a long time,
is if they've followed me for a long time.
Because if you follow me for a year,
you pretty much figure out what I'm up to.
The reason somebody would stay longer
is I'm good at understanding
what's happening right now.
You eventually figure out what I'm up to.
Whether it's the first
day you ever saw me.
How many people here actually,
this is fun for other people to see.
By show of hands,
how many of you, the first
time you came across my stuff
actually thought I was straight dick face,
didn't like me, didn't like it.
Raise your hands, tell the truth.
It doesn't hurt my feelings.
Raise it.
Raise it, right?
So like to me, I know that that
kind of percentage happens.
But I think in a year
or if you catch four or five
pieces of content right,
eventually you're like wait a minute,
I didn't expect to like,
you figure out my gift of
gab makes a lot of people
on initial insight,
or my cursing,
makes people initially be like
this guy's a dickface right?
But my actions win over over time
because of what I'm asking for.
I think that for me,
it's the reason I'm
worth following long term
is I know when audio's popping.
Like I'm pushing some people
here to make an Alexa skill
or a briefing for themselves.
I'm pushing like hey do this podcast
it's gonna matter for him.
And so for me it's been very easy.
It comes natural.
I always recommend for
people that it doesn't
to use other people.
Why do you think almost every
podcast that's successful
interviews somebody else?
I'm like one of the only podcasts
that's straight content to your face.
Every other podcast is
interviewing somebody.
Because it's hard.
You know what's a lot easier?
Asking questions.
So whether it's using
another person to be a guest.
One of the reason I do call in shows
is that's an easy way for the
Ask Gary Vee Show to work.
Right?
Cause I just walk into
Ask Gary Vee like this.
(rolling tongue buzzing)
I'm doing it right now.
And the reason I can do
it is I know my craft.
Pay attention to who doesn't do Q&A.
You want a tell, a subtle tell
on who doesn't know their shit?
Pay attention to who ducks,
some people just don't want
to do Q&A and that's fine.
Watch who ducks Q&A.
I've been able to read people in one sec.
The amount of fakers I
know out there right now,
cause they won't do
Q&A, like contractually.
They don't do Q&A 'cause they're not real.
Super easy to memorize
something and regurgitate it.
It's called an actor.
So using other people.
- [Mike] Thank you.
- You know what else is good?
Using other people at the most macros.
So step one, another
person interview, easy.
Step two, Q&A if you
know you're craft, easy.
Step three, something I've seen nobody do,
that I would love to
do, I'm just too busy,
social commentary.
I love the idea of taking your iPhone.
going to Time's Square,
looking at everybody's sneakers
and talking about sneaker culture
and who's wearing what.
Or going to a whole foods,
and looking at packages and pricing.
Like auditing culture.
It's cool right?
I mean I do it all the time as a person,
but so much of what I know,
I knew slime was coming
for eight year old girls
because I was like watching culture.
Right?
Like I love watching culture.
If you're good enough
if you've always had intuition,
you know how people love
discovering new bands
and then they hold onto it,
and then when the band
gets they get mad at them
'cause they sold out.
You know like if you've got that skill,
try to synthesize that.
That would be a super fascinating thing
to watch or listen to.
I wish I could show where I told you
what was actually going through my head
when I come in to like the airport.
Do you know why I like flying so much?
Watching the people at the airport.
It's how I got on Snapchat so early.
I just kept watching like
teenagers open this yellow app
like five years ago, I
was like what is that?
I went into the app store
and finally it popped up
in the charts like number 130.
I'm like that's the
yellow thing, you know.
I've stopped looking at teenagers as much
'cause some of the dads
we're getting mad at me.
(audience laughs)
but like literally I
was hovering over like.
Like teenage girls will tell
you the future every time.
It's just it's a lot easier
for some of the women in here to do it.
Like creepy 40 year old dude
looking at young kids is kinda weird.
But I watch people.
That would be a cool show, as a third one.
Yes sir.
- [Mike S] Hey Gary, Mike Storne, go Jets.
- Yes sir.
- [Mike S] So as a
disruptor, what's coming,
technical thing.
Michael knows what my questions gonna be.
What do you think about cryptocurrency,
Bitcoin, Ethereum, Dash, Litecoin
as a trending,
- Yeah.
- [Mike S] As a disruptor,
what do you see companies--
- Yeah let's talk about blockchain.
- [Mike S.] Block chain technology.
'Cause it's block chain right?
I mean you got Ethereum underneath that,
you got Bitcoin after that right?
So I invested in Bitcoin
and Ethereum in 2014.
Right so, and I haven't sold any.
So I've done okay right?
But the reason I don't talk about it a lot
for the the people that follow me the most
is I don't like talking
about shit I don't know.
Right and so it's funny,
I talk really, I peacock right?
I roll when I'm talking about what I know.
I know a lot about Crypto,
I spend a lot of time looking at it.
Not enough to put myself out there,
because I feel like I'd
really wanna be right.
Here's the thing with Blockchain.
Blockchain, if you play the
chess moves all the way out
is the decentralization
of our entire society.
Like if you really played
and it seems like you've been
into it for a little while?
- [Mike S] Yeah.
- Bro this is heavy shit.
This isn't Bitcoin.
This isn't like ha, ha, ha.
This is America's not gonna let it happen.
Like 'cause it undermines America itself.
Like China is a funny country.
I think we have American propaganda,
if you look at China, the
mix between dictatorship
communism, and capitalism.
China as a country is run
much more like the way
we run our businesses.
It's a little capitalism,
it's a little bit of right?
So China making it illegal is
the preview, not an anomaly.
We as Americans are like
aw fucking China, right?
Communism right?
China is advanced.
So here's how I think about it.
Look the amount of money
being made on ICO's right now
fast quick bucks,
is no different than Bebo
selling for 850 million dollars to AOL.
There are some people who are
gonna make some real money
in this period.
I love it, I think it's batshit
interesting about you and I.
Me buying your home and
transacting the lease on
the blockchain, right?
Fuck the bank, fuck everybody, like great.
I'm a big buyer in my
altruistic nature as a human.
If you think America
is gonna let it happen
at the level of that extreme?
It has no vested interest.
No government has vested interest
in this collapsing them,
but if you play it out,
outside of military.
This is what holds it
all together, currency.
It's big man, it's real big.
It's really hard for me to
really play out everything,
other than the following.
It is so destructive,
that it's very difficult for me to see
the governments of our society
going down without a fight.
- [Mike S] There's a
window for it for sure.
- Yeah I mean, we're living the window.
You've seen the famous story of the guy
who bought a pizza with
like 10,000 Bitcoins.
Bought pizza for like 50 million dollars.
Like we're living it,
we're in it right now.
A lot of people making a lot of money.
These ICO's, there's so many
rackets being run right now
and so they'll have their window,
but it's fascinating technology, right?
It's like the most disruptive thing that's
since the internet, that I
can even wrap my head around.
Super gnarly shit.
- [Mike S] Thanks.
- You got it.
Hi.
- Hi Gary.
As an entrepreneur looking back
what's something you wish you
would've done more of in your twenties?
- Bought more Google ads.
So like the biggest thesis of me right now
for the people that follow me the most
is I day trade attention.
What I think I'm better at
you know to the point of me putting out
more content consistently than anybody.
It's because I believe
that social networks
have a disproportionate
amount of attention
and people don't realize it.
I just don't understand how
people don't realize it.
Like it's what we spend all our time on.
Like not 14 year olds, 30 year olds,
and 40 year olds, and 50
year olds, and 60 year olds.
Like the social media
celebrities are way more famous
than the actual celebrities.
It's not even close.
I think people are now saying,
"Wait a minute, these people
are kind of famous too."
There's no mainstream celebrity as famous
as any of the top 100 social celebrities.
Including Kardashians
who are as much social
as they are mainstream,
and whatever right?
So I built my dad's liquor store
on the back of email and Google AdWords.
But I didn't spend
enough on Google AdWords.
When I talk about my dad's business
growing from four to 60 million,
every time I hear in an
intro, in an interview
I say it should've been four to 250.
It could've been much bigger
if I was smart enough to
you know, I'm not a poker player
but what I had at the time
by owning all the wine terms on Google
for five and ten cents a click
before anybody knew what it was,
was I had the best hand
and I wasn't going all in.
And that's why I'm so
passionate for all of you
who are serious about social.
Right now Facebook ads is that moment.
And Instagram influencers is that moment.
And I would say everybody in here
is underspending their mental time
and their money on Facebook and Instagram,
much to the demise of their upside.
You could still win.
Direct mail still works,
radio still works,
Google still works.
Things still work, just not as good.
I love when people are
like Gary great great
but I went from zero to four million
this year in my business.
I'm like what's wrong with nine asshole?
(crowd laughs)
So this is about upside,
so really to be honest with you, that.
You know because most
things I don't look back on.
I think looking back is insane.
I think you should learn,
but I'm not good at even
remembering what the fuck
happened last year, let
alone in my twenties.
Because it doesn't matter.
Other than the learnings
that I feel in my body
that help me navigate.
So I don't like to dwell
over things of that nature,
you know the reason I answered that
was so I could go on my rant for you
on Facebook and Instagram right now
because I want you guys to be compelled
to get way more serious.
You know how many people here, Amber?
- [Amber] Yes.
- Amber, do you know
how many people in here
have run a little bit of Facebook ads
with one creative variable,
and it didn't work and they
deemed Facebook as not working.
- [Amber] Maybe not this group,
but most of the people I know.
- This room too.
(audience laughs)
So I'm interested in putting
pressure on that conversation
'cause you will benefit, 'cause
it's under priced attention.
How much you will pay to target people
within a five mile radius of your shop
or people that are
interested in your product,
is under priced.
I just don't know what else to say.
If it costs you three dollars
to get in front of them
it should be 11.
And you're paying 11 somewhere
else and it's worth two.
That's all.
Now, the tough part is you have
to make a picture or video
that makes them do something.
Google was so great for everybody
because it was an intent based marketing.
I am looking for a karate studio.
I am looking for red wine.
Where can I buy bananas?
That was easy.
You just put it in front of them.
The creative part didn't matter,
it was all blue letters.
That's why everybody liked it so much.
We're back to more t.v.
and print, it's harder.
- [Amber] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauding)
Who's got the green thing?
Awesome my man, what's up?
- [Bryce] My name's Bryce.
- Bryce.
- [Bryce] Um you kind of touched
on this a little bit already
but what do you believe holds people back
from just taking action?
- Other people's opinions.
- [Bryce] And how do you overcome that?
- By telling your mom
to go fuck themselves.
(audience laughs)
- Bryce, I'm so hot on this man,
I am so sad that the reason
you get a reaction like that
is a mix between it's funny
to use the word mom and fuck
in the same sentence, right?
But it's way more true.
If you listen to the tone
of the laughs in there
and saw what I just saw.
The truth in what I just
said is so powerful.
I am so sorry,
I am driven by gratitude.
How many saw me on hot ones,
the hot win kind of thing,
some of you saw this?
So that's a huge audience,
and a lot of people that didn't know me.
And every time I do
Joe Rogan, or Hot Wins,
or a t.v. show where a lot of
people don't know who I am,
I know I'm in for it,
because 20% of the crowd's
gonna hate me, right?
But what's fun about YouTube shows
is the comments are there.
So I spent four hours
the other day in there
engaging with the people
that said I was terrible.
But a lot of people spoke what one word,
and they used two different words.
In the comments, one word.
I would say 50 people wrote
in one word on that episode.
Cocaine.
(audience laughing)
And about another hundred wrote,
Aderall.
(audience laughing)
And I replied to every
one of them, all of them.
Especially as someone who's mom
brainwashed them to never even try
smoking a cigarette, right?
I replied, gratitude.
I have so much energy
because I'm grateful.
Not only am I grateful for the
talent I was naturally given,
the ridiculous parents I was given,
and the incredible advantage
of being an immigrant.
I'm grateful that my
parents were so awesome.
They never made me feel inferior, right?
And so many of you,
whether through a sibling or a parent,
had a miserable, sad, negative parent
who tried to impose
their negativity on you.
And misery loves company.
And it's greatest execution
is parents on kids.
That's something we never talk about.
It's not talked about enough.
And so if my legacy when I die,
when I take my last breath,
if you asked me what I
really think I'm gonna think.
I think I'm really gonna think that
I was the human being that came along
and brought the most awareness
to this conversation.
It is my absolute passion.
Because I've seen what
my grandma did to my dad,
and I know what my mom did to me,
and it's a big fucking difference bro,
it's called happiness.
So why do I think a lot
of you don't do shit?
Because you value other
people's opinions of you.
Why do I think you have that?
Because you weren't given
self esteem as a kid,
and you've gone the other way.
And if there's anything
one of the biggest reasons
I act like a bigshot
is because I want kids
to become fans of me
so then I can then become
the shield for them
to have confidence to do
good things, not bad things.
Because if I'm cool,
then they're not talking about Ferraris
and fucking gold watches.
They're talking about hard work,
humility, empathy, and kindness.
(audience applauding)
So I'm in the best place and
the best part of my career
because Snapchat and Instagram and YouTube
have allowed me to get
way down the funnel.
I'm getting to 15 year old dudes,
and 15 year old dudes can
go either way real quick.
And the fact that I'm gonna
get them all to come to me
to become better men,
that's fucking legacy bro.
So through a long winded eight years
I've finally figured out it's that man,
you guys worry about
what other people think.
I brought up this celebrity
thing with Instagram, right?
You just care what other
people think and I don't.
I care what people think
when they know who I am.
But there's people in here
who've literally not done something
'cause they don't like when somebody
leaves an anonymous comment on a picture
that says they're ugly or suck.
And the thought of that, breaks my heart.
I get pumped when people say I suck.
I've only if you follow me carefully,
only in the last three months
because I just wanna help,
I'll tell you why I'm doing it.
Only in the last three months
have I even really gotten
a little more detailed
about Wine Library and the
fact that I own nothing of it,
and I built that business for my dad.
Mainly it's because other kids
who are looking up to me have
other friends that tell them
you can't look up to that guy
his dad gave him a liquor store, he sucks.
So I wanted to kill that excuse
because I don't want these
kids to go down the shit path.
Got it?
Like people think I got something handed.
I had it the reverse.
I gave up the first 13 years of my life
to build my dad's business for him
and left with nothing.
Because I wanted to pay
him and my mom back.
You know, so that's where I'm at.
- [Bryce] Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Wow.
- [Gary] How are ya?
- Hey Gary, I'm well.
- [Gary] Good bro.
- So thank you for coming out today,
it really means a lot to a lot of people,
more than just me.
And he was talking about
leadership with his team,
now you are traveling, going
out, doing all these things,
so you probably don't spend hours--
- [Gary] Correct.
- With your team that's
running your company.
- [Gary] That's right.
- How do you make them feel like--
- [Gary] Listening,
listening.
- You're there?
- I follow every one of
my employees on social.
I see a lot of what's
going on in their lives.
The reason I overspend on a huge HR team
is they're gathering info.
And through Facetime, and
texting, and emojis and emails,
I can get a lot done.
And through osmosis.
Let me tell you how life actually works.
When you're nice to Karen
and you did something right.
Karen tells Susan in the
girls bathroom the truth.
Susan then thinks you're a good person.
Guys, reputation matters.
I'm like what do you
think is going on in life?
When you consistently
do the right thing bro,
you get the halo effect.
You don't need to see everybody.
Brand.
So many people in the
transactional business.
What's my customer acquisition cost?
What was my conversion?
What's my lifetime value?
Cool, if you wanna build something.
It works, it just doesn't
work as big as what I'm up to.
Brand.
So I scale by scaling the unscalable,
which is I don't judge myself
and I do the best I can.
I get to as many people as possible.
I consistently do the right thing.
By the judge and the jury of
the Lord looking down on it.
And I let the osmosis and the
back room chatter scale it.
And then when I don't like it,
and I don't think it's working
I force them to come and see me
one by one for 15
minutes, two times a year.
- [Man In Blue Shirt] There it is.
- You know what I mean,
like it worked for me.
You have to remember how
many people here are parents
that have children that
are over the age of 10
whether they're 10 or 40?
Great.
You know, I'm at eight and five
but they way my life kind of played out,
my little brothers 11 years younger,
I had businesses at 22.
I think I was really built to be a dad,
long before I was a dad.
You don't parent your child at three
the same way you parent them at 11.
They way you parent them at 18,
the way you parent them at 30.
It worked for me, and now I'm changing it.
You have to work for them,
and so you have to keep a pulse on.
So I, all the above.
You know, maybe in the next
two years it'll be 15 minutes
and maybe I'll do so much damage, AKA good
that maybe I can go back
to three years of osmosis.
I don't judge, I just audit
and day trade the moment.
You know what got us all
into this room today,
has nothing to do with what's gonna
get us to the next level.
And way too many people hold
on to what got them here.
'Cause they've got one move, you know.
I think back to fighting,
I'm a big boxing fan,
if you've got one punch,
you can do some damage for a long time.
I got it.
Right?
But once there's enough film on you,
you'll be exposed.
So I'm trying to keep
mixing it up man, right?
- [Man In Blue Shirt] Perfect.
- Look over here, uh.
(audience and Gary laughing)
- [Man In Blue Shirt] Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
Yes, that's right.
Actually this is the first
day I'm wearing them.
I don't know if you guys know this,
I have a sneaker coming out.
I figured if athletes
and rappers can do it,
why can't entrepreneurs?
So this is it, this is the
first day I'm wearing 'em.
- That's awesome.
- This comes out November
14th, I'm pretty pumped.
You know what I love doing?
I love doing things that
are a no lose situation.
So if this works, like works.
Well then I was the first
entrepreneur with a signature
sneaker and it's really
cool in my byline right?
And if it doesn't my buddies
get to make fun of me
for the next 30 years and say
remember when you thought
you were so fucking cool
you could have a sneaker
you fucking asshole?
(audience laughing)
No lose situation.
My man, oh, who's got the?
Are we doing that next?
Yes, go ahead.
- [Robert] Hey Gary, my name's Robert
- Robert.
- [Robert] I've been following
you for quite a while.
- Thanks brother.
- [Robert] So we've started
a webshow on Facebook,
kind of following what you've been doing
and pushed me to do it last year.
- Good for you.
Have you made it a Watch show yet?
Facebook Watch?
This new t.v. thing they're been doing?
- [Robert] No I'm not.
- Okay so you've been putting it on
your Fan page like I was doing.
- [Robert] Yes.
- Go google Facebook Watch,
read an hours worth of,
by the way this is what pisses me off.
Please don't ask me like how
to do something tactical.
I love when people are like
you know in my comments like,
"Gary Vee, like okay enough with the
fucking crush it and rah rah."
"Give me some tactical shit."
Right?
Like, "You suck, give me tactical shit."
I'm like, "You're a fucking asshole."
Tactical shit should be
done on Google and YouTube.
Either you can read or you can watch.
Depending on how you learn,
there's nothing you need from a human.
It's all on the fucking internet for free.
(audience laughing)
Right!
Like everyone's like give
me something tactical.
Oh you mean like when I put out content
about Snapchat for six months
and then all these assholes watch it all,
and package it up into a 397 dollar
How to Win on Snapchat ebook
that makes you feel better, Rick?
You fuckin' idiot.
(audience laughing)
Sorry, go ahead.
- [Robert] It's cool.
- Anyway google that, Facebook Watch.
Learn everything about it.
They're trying to push
their original shows.
How many people here
have hit the video tab
at the bottom of their Facebook
and now have watched a show on there?
So they've picked shows,
like they pay for it,
but then anybody can make a show.
Here's why you always want to do
what a new platform
launches as a new product.
When Instagram launches
stories, or stickers.
Or Facebook Watch or
Twitter does something.
Be smart.
When platforms have a
new feature, they vig it.
So right now if you have
a show on Facebook Watch
that you started,
they're putting it in
to more people's streams
'cause they wanna get
Facebook Watch to work.
So you're riding the wave of Facebook,
and getting the benefit of
people who don't know who you are.
Got it?
- [Robert] Got it.
- Keep going.
- [Robert] All right, so my question is,
we've kind of neglected Instagram,
- That's a mistake.
- [Robert] Not something
I know a ton about.
- Okay.
- [Robert] I have a
couple girls in the school
that have been handling that.
(laughs)
- Sounds about right.
No listen everybody does
it, my niece is, I get it.
Go ahead.
- [Robert] So, I mean, we really wanna
make our focus this year on Instagram
- Good.
- [Robert] 'Cause we've just not done it.
- [Robert] Great place
to start would be where?
- So a couple things first
and foremost for all of you.
The whole girls, or nieces or nephews,
or Rick the 13 year old.
Outsourcing to youth in
social media is insane.
Let me explain why.
Outsourcing to youth that
knows what they're doing
for business is smart.
Just the notion that somebody's 18
and they get it is insane.
You're running a business
not trying to hook up Friday night.
(audience laughing)
So like great, they can slide into the DM
but can they drive your business?
Right?
So first and foremost,
it is no longer an excuse to not know
about Facebook, Instagram,
LinkedIn, YouTube.
How many people here own their business?
Raise their hands.
You need to know what this stuff is.
Are you telling me in 2018
that you don't have 40 hours
this year to allocate into reading
or listening or watching
how to become a practitioner
in social media?
This is the lifeline of
your business right now.
Whether you understand it now,
or you'll understand it later.
Everybody want's to be a
headline reader or outsource
cause they have more important shit to do.
The most important thing
for everybody in this room
is to understand how to
communicate with customers.
And that's on Instagram, and Facebook
and LinkedIn and on and on.
So I implore you number
one, for you to get educated
'cause you have no idea if those two girls
are hosing you or not.
Right?
And then the other thing is,
business people need to get smart.
So many people care about
how many followers and likes they have.
You're not paying your mortgage with
how many likes you get on Instagram.
But it's back to jab jab jab right hook.
Nobody's following you on Instagram
if every fucking post is like
buy my plan, sign up for my course.
Come to my studio.
Give me your money, give me your money.
So the place to start is mental.
The place to start is using this moment
that we have together and saying fuck it,
I need to get smart.
'Cause this is like
balancing my checkbook.
This is like paying my taxes.
It's just real.
Way more real than people think.
And let me tell you why.
Forget about all these social networks.
The next thing, voice, AR, VR,
or something I don't know yet.
It's gonna be the same principal as this.
The reason I'm so good at social
is because I cut my teeth
on Google and email,
and then didn't hold romantic to it
and became even better at
the next thing, got it?
So you guys are running
a marathon in life,
and so I wanna get you on
the treadmill on social now
'cause it's gonna be a proxy
to the next thing you have to do.
How many people are retiring
in the next ten years?
And I don't mean that
you're gonna crush it,
sell your business and buy an island.
I mean your old and
you're fucking finished.
(audience laughing)
Two.
Respect.
For the rest of you,
for the rest of you, what
do you think has happened
in the last ten years?
Let me remind you,
basically everything that we live on now.
Smartphones, social networks, everything.
What the hell do yo think is
coming in the next ten years?
And if you're outsourcing social now,
you have no prayer in
understanding Crypto,
or AR or VR, or everything
that's coming next.
You need to get on it now.
Don't you love, I mean, back to training.
I love the fighting analogy stuff,
I'm just such a big fan of it
'cause it has such proxies.
(snapping)
Or it's like doing business
in China or Russia.
The naivete of an American
going doing business
in China or Russia is so funny to me.
They think it's the same rules, right?
Or when you get a tough guy
into mixed martial arts
'cause they were good at boxing.
It's a different sport man.
Like so we know it in our things,
but then in business we do the same shit.
We make fun of people who
don't work out consistently
and think like a pill or
a drug is gonna do it.
You gotta do the right things,
you gotta eat right, you gotta,
but then in business, all the
muscles heads on Instagram
that DM me, make me laugh so much.
They stay disciplined in the gym,
and they way they eat,
but in business they're
looking for the short cut.
Which is the exact thing
they make fun of in fitness.
- Good point.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- Like all my fucking
buffed out buddies are like
no, no but Gary what's the fuckin',
I'm like dude there is no
steroids in fucking business.
(audience laughing)
You know like, it is what it is.
My man.
- Hey Gary.
(muffled speaking)
- [Gary] Thank you brother, I could tell,
thank you for the love.
- My wife got it for my birthday,
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- I had to wear it.
So I hear you talk a lot about B2C stuff.
- [Gary] Yes.
B&B.
- So what do you think is the best way
to gain attention B&B.
Would you still say it's--
- [Gary] Media company.
- Yes, but.
- Dude, you have it better.
So I've done much better
with my B&B investments
than my B2C investments in
helping them on social media.
You literally know the names of
the people you're trying reach.
(scoffs)
I mean that's insane.
You know how awesome that is?
Vayner's been a gift
compared to Wine Library.
Anybody potentially
could've been interested
in buying wine, beer, and liquor.
VaynerMedia's super simple,
I'm like I need the CMO
of Kraft and Procter
and you know Toyota and Pepsi.
So I would make content
on Instagram, excuse me
on LinkedIn and Facebook with ad dollars
targeting employees of the organizations
that you're trying to get to.
Guys, how many people B2B in here?
So just for a couple of you, great.
Higher hands, I just want to get a sense.
Don't be scared.
Okay, so to me, back to
the last question, right?
Being a practitioner.
When you run a Facebook ad
you can run against anything.
How many people here have
spent 100 thousand dollars
on Facebook and they were the people
that clicked buttons
and made the creative?
Raise your hand.
Right, two.
This is huge, this is huge.
This is a huge opportunity.
When you become a
practitioner of Facebook ads
you'll shit your pants of how good it is.
It's incredible.
You can run ads against employees of,
give me company that you'd
love to use your B2B product.
Give me one.
(muffled speaking)
What's that?
(laughing)
Yours? (audience laughing)
Good, you can literally make a video
that targets their employees on Facebook,
and literally the creative,
the writing or the video
says, "Does your CEO know?"
And then you could literally
forward it to them,
like you can literally
target him on LinkedIn.
It's incredible.
You know the names.
But you have to make the creative smart.
So a lot of people in B2B,
the CIO, or CTO, or CFO is the
person making the decision.
And people say to me,
they're not on Facebook.
I'm like, I get it.
So run ads against the
employees of the company
and the title of the video
is, Does Your CFO Know?
Then the CFO gets 13 emails
and she's like, what the hell is this?
She watches it and then she contacts you.
It happens everyday.
B2B's incredible in social.
- [Man In Hat] Now in martial arts world.
- Yes.
- [Man In Hat] A lot of the
businesses are small businesses
like family owned businesses--
- Great, go to Instagram and Twitter
where they're half-assing it,
and DM them since they never get any Dms.
They'll be like cool I got a DM.
And instead of saying buy my shit.
Bring them some value.
Listen, always listen.
Figure out what they're struggling with.
And give them, make an ebook,
or a Powerpoint, or a video for free
that takes you some time and money.
And then DM them and say, "Hey."
"Number one thing I've noticed
in the mixed martial arts
world is that studios
aren't doing the following."
And it's titled 11 things
you should be doing.
It'll be three minutes and 19 seconds.
You'll give them value.
And one in every three of them
will look deeper into you
and give you business.
- [Man In Hat] That's awesome.
- We have to start with value.
You know, it's funny.
Women entrepreneurs are
always more intuitive
to my style of marketing because
they've been the ones hit on and sold to.
Right?
So they intuitively understand
they respond more when
there's value brought upfront.
You know and so there's
a very small and smart
cadence of hunting and
farming, bringing value.
We need to romance our
customers a little bit more.
Value, it always wins.
We're sold to all the time, right?
- It's so true.
- We're pounded.
Like do you know what
everybody's LinkedIn strategy is?
Bulk spam email.
- Yes. (laughing)
- Just gonna email everybody until,
like I know some of it works
it just it works a hell of a lot better
if you bring some value.
Next.
- [Man In Purple Shirt] Hi Gary, big fan.
- Thank you.
- I had my martial arts students,
I posted a thing on the Facebook page,
"What would you ask Gary Vee?"
One question and the
most response that I got
and maybe you already covered it--
- [Gary] That's okay.
- I don't know.
As an immigrant--
- [Gary] Yes.
- You came to the United States.
- The value of the
American flag in public--
- [Gary] Yes.
- How do you feel about the
stance on kneeling in the NFL--
- [Gary] Yup.
- And if you were an owner
of the New York Jets--
- [Gary] Yes.
- How would you handle
that with your players?
- Yeah, so, couple things.
First and foremost, when
you're an owner in the NFL,
you have to worry about
the other 31 owners.
So the way I would handle it,
is first get a pulse of what my other
31 business partners thought.
As far as kneeling, you
know this is where Americans
are often times confused
from a kid that was born
in the Soviet Union.
The thought of not allowing people
to express themselves in any shape or form
including if it really hurt your feelings
is something that I'm just not
willing to go down that path.
So if we're gonna respect our amendments,
if we're gonna respect number two
with the right to bear arms,
we're gonna respect number
with freedom of speech.
And so it would not bother me
if a player kneeled during
the national anthem.
I'm awfully aware that
that breaks peoples hearts.
It makes them mad at me for that stance,
it's just how I feel about it.
Because I think most of the
people making comments about it
have never lived in a communist country
and know what it tastes
like to not have the option.
(audience applauding)
- [Man In Blue Collared
Shirt] It's the whole
that's their job.
They're overpaid athletes--
- They're not overpaid athletes.
They're not overpaid athletes.
- [Man In Purple Shirt] That's my stance.
- No, no, I, listen, I
understand the stance.
And by the way, the great
thing about our country
is I'm deeply empathetic
and respect the living shit
out of somebody's opinion the other way.
I would just remind people,
they're definitely not overpaid
because they're paid based on the reality
of what the market conditions created.
We allowed them to be paid this way
because we drive the revenue.
If everybody wants to
stop watching football
and drive that down, they're
more than welcome to.
I've had a lot of fun
with a lot of my friends
who take the other stance,
they don't like pro football.
But when their homies at
Alabama, and LSU, and Texas
start kneelin', they like their Longhorns.
They care about their 'Bama boys.
So it's been really interesting to watch.
I have a lot of empathy
and I'm super in tune with it
because of the communist you know
freedom of speech kind of thing.
It's so deep in my, you
know, both my grandfathers
spent ten years in jail in
Russia 'cause they were Jewish.
So you know, I also have the benefit
of having six of my eight
core friends in college
be African-Americans which
led to me going to the mall
the first four times in college
and getting pulled over three times.
Like the big thing that we're missing
in our country right now is empathy.
We're not putting ourselves
in other people's shoes,
and we're letting
everything get politicized.
Like are we gonna make
everything a political issue?
Because basically we're in a
emotional civil war right now.
Which is cool, I'm fine with it.
Every empire should fall.
- [Man In Blue Collared Shirt] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Andy, how are we on time?
(audience applauding)
- [Man In Gray shirt] Hey Gary.
- Hey, brother.
- You use a lot of fight analogies
and we're in a room of
tons of martial artists
and mixed martial artists.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- And I know VaynerSports
I haven't seen any sign
in mixed martial artists.
- [Gary] Nope.
- I don't know if you guys
with the UFC doing the
four billion dollar deal.
- [Gary] Yup.
- What do you think is the
future of mixed martial arts?
What industry or opportunistically,
what do you see coming for it?
- Yeah, listen, fighting
is as old as ever.
You know, it is core.
It probably was the first sport, right?
If I had to bet on it,
it was the first sport.
Maybe racing you know,
I'm trying to think about
like how it went down.
Nonetheless, VaynerSports
is only football right now.
The next two sports that we'll expand into
based on mine and A.J.'s interests
are most likely esports and the NBA.
We haven't really thought about going into
repping talent in the UFC
and mixed martial arts.
I'm extremely bullish on it.
I think it's an extremely
lucrative category and territory.
And so, we haven't thought
about expanding it there next
'cause we've got a
little bit of a road map.
A.J.'s really running VaynerSports
and I'm like creating the halo effect.
And so I'll have to react to where
he sees some of the opportunities as well.
So that's kind of where we're at.
But like, A--
Yeah, please
- The athletes make a fraction in MMA
of what's sort of repping them.
There's not as much money
to be made in MMA athlete
compared to NBA or NFL or anything else.
- Yeah, I mean I think
that can change, right?
Yeah I never make decisions
based on what it is now,
it's more about my
anticipation to your point.
It'll be interesting
to see how it evolves.
Look, I think fighting,
you know, in whatever form
is always quite lucrative
'cause it's so primal to us.
The thought of like the big event
where two people fight is so
100% always gonna be there.
For us, we just have a lot
of interest in the NBA,
and the esports thing is
super interesting to me.
Like to me, if VaynerSports
was here 12 years ago
I would've done UFC.
To me I wanna catch something
in a different part,
you know NBA and NFL's interest graph
esports over UFC on the base
of the maturity of the market.
The less mature something is,
the more opportunity there is.
And so for me, I wanna be looking at that.
- [Man In Gray Shirt] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauding)
- Okay, one last question and then--
- Yeah, that's good.
- Hi.
- Hi, Luisa.
So my question may not
apply to many of you
but it was triggered by
what you said about being an immigrant.
- [Gary] Yes.
- 'Cause I'm one of them.
- [Gary] Yes, I can tell.
- From Poland.
- [Gary] Yes.
- So what would you advise
to the person who came from
the Communistic country
who came with the mindset
of working super hard,
I know you're laughing already
because I spoke with you about it.
So working super hard and you finally
end up being just trapped
that even when you succeed
at like, you know, thanks to the people at
my school, I grew by 400% over two years.
So that's quite a big hit.
- [Gary] Yes.
So now everything goes so much better,
I end up not being able to
stop myself from working.
- [Gary] Do you want to?
- And there's a fear
of just failing down--
- [Gary] Sure.
- 'Cause what if I lose
everything what I have?
- [Gary] Yup.
- I also feel like I'm in a
conflict of the whole family,
and mindset of my whole family
because now I think different
and I know I can be happy,
I know I can be grateful
and I know I can succeed
but Polish people don't think this way
because we're used to just
being communistic country
and always not having anything.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
So, I mean, look there's a lot there.
And stay here so we can go back and forth.
Stay at the mic.
So I think look, first of all
the back half of your question
was the whole point that
I made earlier which is
if you could go inside my brain
and my feelings and my DNA right now,
it would either scare you or confuse you
how much I do not allow my
wife, children or parents
to factor into the way
I think about things.
At the same token, their
opinions of me are my life.
You have to find the
calibration of respecting
people's opinions,
but now allowing them
to dictate your actions
because you're gonna go down the path
of becoming bitter with them at the end.
Too many of us protect our
family and pander to them
because we wanted to be good,
without realizing how
it plays out in the end
which is in our older years.
We have a lot of resentment towards them
'cause we think we allowed
them to dictate our behavior.
But that's not true.
So you know, listen, we
share a lot common themes.
I understand.
First of all, on the working part,
first you have to ask yourself if you,
do you want to work less?
I'm asking.
- [Luisa] Yes.
- Well then work less.
(audience laughing)
- [Luisa] Yes.
- You know what I mean?
The way you gotta think about it is,
whatever management you put in or
whatever happens, first you have to
immediately think it's gonna do less.
Second, you can't hold
your managers accountable.
One thing I know about
eastern European employers
is when they do moves like that
they expect those people to work
like a horse the way they did.
It's not their business.
Unless you're willing to give your manager
the same amount of money
and a piece of the business,
why should he or she work as hard as you?
So first you have to deploy
practicality, reality.
And everything, my friends, has a price.
Everything.
So if you want to work less,
and take spa treatment and go fishing
and pick up basketball
or learn how to sing,
or whatever the fuck you want,
well know that it comes at the expense
of your business growing.
And that's okay.
And once you learn how to stop
thinking about the judgment
of others on your behavior,
everything opens up.
Easy to say but it
takes a lot of practice.
And it starts with,
the reason I always say
fuck you mom, fuck you dad.
It starts with practice.
If you sit down in your family and be like
I'm doing this,
I know exactly what you're thinking.
It's my life.
I'm sorry if it hurts your feelings
this is what I'm doing.
'Cause I don't wanna resent.
The way I do it is tell the truth,
I don't want to resent you later.
I always tell people, whenever
I had to have that talk
with my dad or mom or brother,
I always tell people, I'm gonna break.
And if I break, then it's all broken.
And I promise you, when
you put them into a corner
instead of them putting you into a corner,
it gets real funny.
I'm fascinated by bullying in general
and families bully the
moneymaker in their family.
And a funny thing happens
when you go and treat them like a bully.
They fold like a cheap chair,
'cause they have no fucking leverage.
(Gary laughing)
You like that right?
Hits home right?
When you're the moneymaker,
everybody gets real used to you.
When you flip it on them,
they've got no move.
Let them go make money.
- [Luisa] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauding)
It's a real thing, like
it's hard for a lot of us.
If we're the driver,
people get into a cadence
and look when you know how to make money
you start taking on almost
this responsibility.
You start helping.
You love your family,
I love everybody.
I fucking love you guys, I
don't even fucking know you.
- [Man In Audience] Thank you.
- You know?
Like you start getting into that place
and then everybody gets
into their position.
I'm okay with it, you're okay with it,
we'll get to you in a second.
Like you can be okay with it
you can be okay with eating
shit your whole life.
I've eaten more shit than
anybody i've ever seen.
The problem is.
No, no problem.
The problem is, once you're at a place
where you don't want to
do it anymore, you act.
See what their move is to that.
It's just practice, one time.
Not when you're drunk.
Not when it's so crazy that
you can't deal with it anymore.
A month, a year before you break
and go crazy and yell at them
at the top of your lungs.
Calm nice dinner and be
like here's the score.
It's incredible.
I've given this advice a lot,
it's been game changing
for people's lives.
When they've acted on it
most don't act on it, 'cause it's hard.
I don't think what I just said is easy.
It's super hard.
And the longer it's been
real, the harder it is, right?
- [Kelly] Hi there, I'm Kelly.
- Hi Kelly.
- [Kelly] I work for Michael.
- Very nice, sorry.
(audience laughs)
- So as you mentioned before,
this is a media business first.
And obviously I look at Proxain.
we have over 250 locations open.
Another 800 to open soon.
- [Gary] Incredible.
- It does become difficult when
you have lots of different levels of
competency when it comes
to our franchisees.
Some of them don't even
have a Facebook to start.
- [Gary] Yes.
- So as we grow and as we expand,
is it more important for us
to control the content of our brand?
Because it does take away the intimacy
and personal touch for
each market, but also--
- [Gary] Yeah.
- We never know who's
representing our brand.
- So VaynerMedia works (sound cutting out)
You know a real estate group
that we're about to announce.
We'll announce in thirty days.
This is a super tough question.
My answer is that you do both
and let me explain what I mean by that.
I think that you guys should be
overly aggressive on a national scale
in your areas as an advertiser.
And whether it's co-op
dollars or you do it,
you guys decide.
And I think you spend a lot of time on
teaching and giving best practices
to your franchisees.
Creating ways to communicate them.
I have a really good idea.
I think you guys should start
an internal B2B podcast.
An internal B2B podcast
for your franchisees
around best practices.
- Or just social media.
- Correct, or whatever you
deem is most important.
Management style, how to treat employees,
whatever your religious pillars are.
Because one more time, how
many people listen to my audio?
The reason there's so
many more hands by average
is because you guys are busy
and audio is a good thing.
A lot of these franchisees
are busy, so let them,
even if they live six
minutes from their location
let them hear you for 12 hours a day.
12 minutes excuse me a day, right?
I would advertise on top of them,
and then I would spend a lot of time,
I think of it as high low,
I think most people are in the middle.
They're kinda doing it as a corporation.
They're kinda servicing their people.
They giving them a tool kit
or something that they never open.
They do a one time a year event
and bring up the person that
does social media the best
and give them a trophy and
think it's gonna inspire, no.
Internal podcast, really
educate, really get them there.
And also advertise, so
that you can point to it
and say look how good
this piece of content did.
Email them all.
- Well we actually advertise,
we do about a million a quarter.
We advertise on our behalf, exclusively.
- Yeah, so to me it's
synthesizing what's working
and send out again I don't
think they read email,
but listening.
And so maybe like,
maybe in your 30 minute,
15 minute you know again interview people,
you have a lot of relationships.
You could really crush that.
You could get really fancy
people on your podcast.
Like you have an advantage
with him and his relationships.
I think I'm very very big on audio.
Very big, it's big.
Like if I was creating VaynerMedia today,
it would be called Vayner Voice.
If I started today, I
would call it Vayner Voice.
I would deeply position
myself in Alexa, Google,
and you know all that,
building apps for that world.
Just like iPhone apps in 2007,
and I would be very big on
being the infrastructure
for companies around
their internal podcasts.
I mean, I'm putting the
money where my mouth is.
I just renovated for two million dollars
a 40 thousand square foot,
50 thousand square foot
studio in Long Island City
to do video and audio production.
So I believe in it tremendously.
- [Kelly] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauding)
- One more?
Okay, this is the last one
and then we'll do pics, okay.
- My name is Vlad.
My question to you is, when
you go on to branding--
- [Gary] Yes.
- Like you and the media accompanying
you, like you were saying--
- [Gary] Yes.
- Do you grant yourself or do you
grant the corporation you're representing?
- [Gary] That's a great question.
I think both can work, Vlad.
You know, I think, first of all,
if you're an introvert and you want
your privacy and you don't like it,
you should never force yourself.
There's plenty of humongous companies
where you don't know the founder.
I always get worried that people,
like, I like it, I like the admiration,
I like the interaction, I like all of it
so to me, the first and foremost is
you realize, either way can work.
I will say, if you like it and you're
a good person and you don't take down
the company with your
off the field activities,
it's a great way to go and that's
why I'm very comfortable with it.
- [Vlad] So you would
go, let's say you have
a Facebook business page, all right.
- Yes.
- [Vlad] And you have multiple locations
and then you have their own profile.
- You mean like Facebook
slash Wine Library
and Facebook slash Gary Vee?
- [Vlad] Yes and then, yeah.
(clicking tongue, audience laughing)
So you would make multiple videos
or you would like take
two tablets and run--
- Content for the context.
Once in awhile, if something
was super important
I'd post on both, but a business
talking and a human talking should be
putting out different stuff.
People use social media as distribution,
not as a place to narrow
make native content.
They they think of social as email.
I'll take something and I'll post
it on all my accounts.
They don't take into
a fact the psychology.
Do you know the difference between
a 40 year old woman with two kids
when she's on Pinterest and on Facebook?
Totally different.
Her psychology, her psychology when she's
on Facebook is to keep up
with her friends and news.
On Pinterest, it's aspiration
to shop or escapism.
You have to give her content that fits
her psycho state, not just
her demographic state.
Got it?
Think about how you guys use Facebook,
Instagram, Snapchat.
Even right now, I can see some of you
picking up on this, you're
even thinking different.
Like, your in a different,
one place is entertainment,
one place is information.
LinkedIn, you're a different person
than you are on Facebook.
Your head's in a different place.
I gotta feed you content.
The subtle things that I do that
people aren't picking up on
has more to do with that.
Why do I make Meme videos on Instagram?
Why did that same video
look different on Facebook?
Why do I chop up what I chop?
Why is the copy different on the
Facebook post and the Twitter post?
Why do I use hashtags on
Instagram but not on Facebook?
The subtleties of the craft.
I have a knack of making things
look easy but this shit is real.
(smacking)
- [Vlad] Thank you.
- You're welcome, Vlad.
Thank you for having me.
(audience applauding)
- Want the photo line right up here?
- Yeah.
- That's awesome, thanks man, good stuff.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat hip hop music)